Este es el momento en que la vida de la
Estrella de 19 años cambió para siempre
[Aplausos]
Víctor When banyama La promesa del
baloncesto más esperada desde Lebron
James elegido número uno del Draft de la
NBA el jueves se vivieron escenas
salvajes cuando los San antonios furgs
consiguieron por fin a su hombre un
escolta francés de dos metros y 24
centímetros con el mundo a sus pies y a
pesar de que la selección era una
conclusión Inevitable su reacción lo
dijo todo
[Música]
realmente no puedo describirlo acaba de
ocurrir Bueno
una de las mejores sensaciones de mi
vida probablemente la mejor noche de mi
vida
El joven jugador viene con mucho más
bombo que la mayoría de los números uno
ya que dominó la liga francesa en su
última temporada con los 92 sumó las
mejores marcas en anotación rebotes y
bloqueos ahora espera utilizar su
talento generacional para convertirse en
la pieza central de un equipo necesitado
de estrellas y tiene el mentor perfecto
el entrenador
que llevó a los spools a la victoria de
cinco campeonatos es Víctor y eso es lo
que quiero que sea por supuesto que
cualquiera estaría emocionado por
conseguir la elección número uno del
Draft Así que estoy muy emocionado
no quieres que salte arriba y abajo
verdad que Monte un espectáculo para ti
daría una voltereta Pero estaría fuera
tres meses
las últimas dos veces que los Sports
tuvieron la primera elección ganaron la
lotería con los futuros miembros del
Salón de la Fama David a Robinson y Team
Duncan ahora comienza la era o en
banyama donde cualquier cosa en la
cancha es posible